sind da wenn sie diese bilder sehen aus
der hauptstadt afghanistans wo die
taliban eben jetzt immer weiter
vorrücken die hauptstadt wahrscheinlich
in wenige stunden in wenigen tagen unter
ihre kontrolle bringen was geht ihnen da
durch den kopf oder nimmt die deutsche
politik dass er mit schulterzucken zur
kenntnis
na ja ist schon
ein ziemliches desaster wenn wir ehrlich
sind jetzt nähert sich bald der elfte
september 20 jahre und genau zum 20
jährigen jubiläum ist genau diese gruppe
die dann quasi damals mitverantwortlich
war zumindest teilweise für die
schlimmen ereignisse ist wieder zurück
an der macht und die art und weise wie
das jetzt so stattfindet nahezu kampflos
die übergabe das in die hände fallen
auch von verschiedensten modernen
militärischen material ist ja gerade
bewusst der afghanischen armee zur
verfügung gestellt wurde und auch quasi
die hilflosigkeit in bezug auf diesen
vormarsch ist schon echt erschütternd
und das zeigt doch nur dass diese 20
jahre offenkundig sinnlos gewesen sind
deswegen ist es schon unterm strich eine
der größten niederlagen auch der
westlichen politik das muss man ganz
offen zu sagen und ich hoffe nicht dass
es am ende so wird wie in saigon die
bilder dass dann der letzte hubschrauber
verlässt so ähnlich wirkt es da muss
jetzt noch mit dringend was überlegt
werden es kann nicht so einfach dass man
nur schulter und achselzucken dann dabei
steht und das ganze zur kenntnis nimmt
aber was tun jetzt haben wir uns die
situation ich tatsächlich genauso selbst
eingebrockt
der völlig überraschende abzug oder der
zum teil überstürzten abzug der
amerikaner ist natürlich die
hauptursache die bundeswehr kann nicht
allein dort bleiben wenn die amerikaner
abziehen deswegen ist auch ganz klar
dass da sicherlich die
hauptverantwortung daran liegt trotzdem
wäre sinnvoll jetzt eine rasche beratung
zu finden nicht nur der europäischen
union sondern vor allem in der nato es
braucht eine nato sondersitzung darüber
zu reden wie geht man jetzt damit um mit
den amerikanern zusammen überlegen
welche folgen hat es denn die folgen
sind ja dreifach zu sehen die eine folge
ist natürlich was bedeutet es für die
internationalen terror wege kann sich in
afghanistan erneut zu einem zentrum für
terrorismus in der welt entwickeln was
dramatisch wäre und wie sieht man sich
dem vor zweitens ist auch die frage
natürlich wie geht man mit der drogen
fragen um denn das ist eine der größten
anbaugebiete für drogen in den westen
hinein was wird damit wie geht man damit
um und natürlich auch die frage welche
schutzaufgaben gibt das ich halte es
jetzt für sehr sinnvoll dass die
bundeswehr auch noch zusammen mit den
amerikanern schutzdienst leistet das
heißt nicht nur die deutschen
staatsbürger auszufliegen sondern
diejenigen die als er arzt kräfte mit
unterstützt haben das habe ich ganz auch
zwingend geboten dazu helfen aber es
muss auch klar gestellt werden dass es
auf der einen seite hilfsangebote gibt
aber keine komplett neue
flüchtlingswelle und wie man für
möglicherweise mit diesem ansehen umgeht
ich hätte mir gut vorstellen können dass
man beispielsweise noch eine zeitlang
eine schutzzone in kabul einrichtet aber
durch die tatsache dass die afghanische
regierung selber nahezu eine art
kapitulation macht eine friedliche
übergabe wird auch dieses modell nicht
funktionieren also eine wirklich
wirklich schwierig es ist diese drei
punkte schon genannt die können wir der
reihe noch mal nach noch einmal
durchgehen vielleicht schauen wir noch
mal auf die aktuellen bilder sie haben
das historisch gerade schon eingeordnet
und gesagt hoffentlich dritter nicht
eine situation wie in saigon ein
tatsächlich liegen diese bilder das ja
nahe dass das heutige bild aus
afghanistan aus kabul also
us-hubschrauber die dort ihre leute in
die sicherheit bringen und rechts sehen
sie die historischen bilder damals von
saigon die rettung aus der us-botschaft
das heißt diese bilder gleichen sich ja
jetzt schon wie konnte überhaupt so eine
situation eintreffen dass man jetzt im
grunde in den letzten stunden ja
abhängig ist nur noch davon ja ob die
taliban gnädig sind gegenüber den
letzten deutschen gegenüber den letzten
amerikanern die dort in der hauptstadt
noch leben
ich bin kein verteidigungspolitik ich
bin noch kein mitglied der
bundesregierung gestern einmal
informiert worden rudimentär über die
lage aber sie haben natürlich recht wenn
man sich jetzt die gesamte wegstrecke
anschaut sicherlich hat es viel gutes
gegeben die ausbildung eine ganze
generation ist ausgebildet worden das
hat auch viel ich gute hilfe gegeben
aber politisch strategisch und
militärisch ist die bilanz am ende
verheerend und offenkundig ist auch die
afghanische armee nicht in der lage
gewesen oder auch gar nicht willens
entsprechend widerstand zu leisten was
mir deswegen auch sorge macht ist dass
wir am grunde genommen jetzt das ganze
material des europäer und amerikaner
geliefert haben jetzt kampflos in die
hände auch der taliban fällt das heißt
die taliban sind danach sogar noch
stärker auch militärisch gesehen und es
macht mir schon sorge deswegen braucht
es auch eine eine nato sondersitzung und
zu überlegen wie man damit umgeht und
was die zukünftige rolle von afghanistan
sein ich habe gehört einige politiker
aus dem bund fordern jetzt auch keine
entwicklungshilfe mehr für die taliban
gegeben sicherlich klar und richtig aber
das reicht nicht es reicht übrigens auch
nicht nur zu sagen wir nehmen jetzt
quasi wie wir bieten eine art offene
möglichkeit an für eine neue
flüchtlingswelle helfen ja natürlich
aber wir können auch nicht die sorgen
ganz afghanistans in deutschland oder in
europa aufnehmen also deswegen braucht
es zum zweiten nimmt man nato rat auch
eine eine eu sondersitzung um sich damit
zu beschäftigen und möglicherweise auch
zu reagieren was passiert mit mit einer
möglichen großen flüchtlingssituation
wir haben die amerikaner bereits
ausgeflogen haben haben die deutschen
noch geplant warum
na ja die frage muss man an anderen
stellen was mich am meisten so ein
bisschen irritiert ist dass es zwischen
usa und deutschland nicht so einfach
scheint also dass die amerikaner auch
sehr einseitig handeln das ist da auch
keine am ende absprachen gegeben hat ich
finde es jetzt sehr sehr gut dass die
kanzlerin jetzt in den nächsten tagen
sich mit allen partnern zusammensetzt
und darüber redet wie es weitergeht aber
ich finde unter beiden ist vieles besser
als unter trump vor allem vom thron aber
es bleibt doch eine einseitigkeit
entscheidung und der usa leider kennt
sie haben gerade gesagt die muss sich
anderen stellen sie sind natürlich nicht
dafür verantwortlich aber wir müssen wir
sie fokussiert stellen der deutschen
verteidigungsministerium logischerweise
ja ich glaube ich muss zunächst mal die
bundesregierung da ist auch eine antwort
darauf geben die bundesregierung ist der
seit gestern auch unterwegs und und
arbeitet und hat auch vorschläge gemacht
ich glaube dass es jetzt ganz
entscheidend ist dass das diesem
einzelstaatlichen verbund heraus die
multilateralen prozess gehen sofort
darauf ein herr söder das ist auch
tatsächlich der blick nach vorne nur
erstmal geht es ja einfach um die
rettung deutscher
staatsangehöriger dort und auch die
werden natürlich die frage stellen warum
die amerikaner schon fliegen und sie
hier noch sitzen vielleicht hängt es
damit zusammen dass beispielsweise am 9
juni im bundestag noch der außenminister
gesagt hat so eine situation werde nicht
eintreffen da gehe er nicht davon aus
dass kabul jetzt schnell an die taliban
fallen das heißt man hat das ja offenbar
total unterschätzt
also es ist ja allein schon die tatsache
dass wir brauchen wieder ein neues
mandat darüber diskutiert man hat wohl
auch etliche stunden mit der spd
gerungen ob die spd bereit ist ein neues
mandat zu erteilen dafür was ehrlich
weil sie völlig unverständlich ist zur
rettung deutscher staatsbürger übrigens
auch zur unterstützung der da die wii
deutschen unterstützt haben die
bundeswehr und viele kräfte also die
sogenannten arzt kräfte ist auch
selbstverständlich dass man da eine
unterstützung der rettung geben muss
dass man da überhaupt lange über mandats
fragen dieses muss schnell geklärt
werden es scheint jetzt dann im lauf des
tages gestern passiert zu sein das ist
okay aber schneller hätte vielleicht
immer gehen können wir haben hier bei
bild live in den vergangenen tagen und
wochen immer wieder soldaten gesehen die
ihren afghanistan einsatz hinter sich
haben und die sagen was ist davon übrig
geblieben das war umsonst wir haben auch
angehörige mütter gefallener soldaten
gesehen die gesagt haben mein sohn ist
ganz offenbar umsonst gestorben was
sagen sie diesen müttern was sagen sie
diesen soldaten
umsonst vor der gesamte dienst nicht
wenn man 20 jahre einen neuen generation
alle möglichkeiten geboten hat auch
frieden auf ausbildung einer ganzen
generation von jungen mädchen hoffnung
gemacht wird hat und und und auch
hoffnung gegeben hat das problem ist
jetzt was passiert jetzt dann danach
denn die situation ist ja aus hat mich
schwierig also wie hoch ist der druck
auf die taliban ist das jetzt einfach so
dass man sich abwendet weil sie habe es
vorhin mal so angedeutet in der frage
man sagt man nimmt das jetzt zur
kenntnis das war's wir wollen nichts
mehr von afghanistan hören andere länder
scheinen ja schon wie der clio
strategisches interesse daran entwickeln
zu wollen oder ob man jetzt tatsächlich
sieht noch einmal bemüht ist eingebettet
internationale initiativen und das ist
jetzt gefragt dass der westen insgesamt
international jetzt nach 20 jahren mit
diesem ergebnis dann letztlich eine
bilanz präsentiert ist unterm strich
jedenfalls auch für den westen
international natürlich sehr verheerende
bilanz was doch klar es ist dass die
probleme afghanistans wieder zu uns
kommen das zeigen ja die bilder und
parolen hat er mitgebracht aus kabul vor
allen dingen von passamt dort also wenn
wir da sehen wie lange schlangen dort
schon vor zwei zweieinhalb wochen waren
und die situation hat sich natürlich
noch drastisch verschlechtert dort noch
mehr menschen viel mehr menschen drängen
nach außen zunächst meist nach pakistan
aber da wenn man sie fragt das hat paul
ii dort gemacht dann äußern die meisten
sie wollen nach deutschland droht da die
nächste flüchtlingswelle die hertha noch
rechnen sie fest mit der nächsten
flüchtlingswelle
ich rechne schon mit einer großen
herausforderung
es manches verständlich aber umgekehrt
kann nicht alles allein von europa oder
auch deutschland an der stelle gelöst
werden das sind zum beispiel auch die
amerikaner aus meiner sicht in erster
linie gefordert dafür eine antwort zu
bieten denn die amerikaner waren
federführend in diesem einsatz haben
auch federführend jetzt entschieden das
land zu verlassen und das sind müssen
auch die amerikaner zunächst mal die
eine der der der wichtigsten lösungen
anbieten dafür es kann jetzt nicht
deutschland oder allein schultern
deswegen glaube ich wird das nicht so
möglich sein trotzdem werden wir uns mit
der situation auch stellen und
diskutieren müssen aber jetzt also jetzt
ist ja noch die zeit davor und jetzt
könnte man sich überlegen beispielsweise
kontingente festzulegen welche position
hat man denn es werden ja auf jeden fall
mehr menschen von dort nach deutschland
drängen als man aufnehmen möchte
vermutlich als man aufnehmen kann das
heißt sind sie für eine solche
kontingent lösung
wir haben uns hier auf bundesebene im
etwa doch vereinbart auch über kundige
insgesamt zu reden die deutschland pro
jahr aufnehmen kann man wird auch
sicherlich nochmal über die
sondersituation afghanistan reden es ist
nur klar wir können keine zweite
situation im jahr 2015 erleben da war ja
die eigentliche problematik nicht die
hilfe die man gegeben hat sondern das
darauffolgende darauffolgende zeit in
der es keine kontrollen keine lenkung
gegeben hat da muss jetzt die
bundesregierung mal eine analyse
erstellen wie es die tat sich die
situation jedenfalls zuge die grünen
einfach blankoschecks auszustellen noch
bevor wissen was tatsächlich stattfindet
das ist schwierig das ist übrigens
deswegen nicht einfach denn wenn die
grünen von vornherein sagen noch vor der
burg so zu sagen wir nehmen auf www ist
man als zusätzlich migrationsdruck aus
hinzu kommt es müssen auch andere
partner noch diskutiert werden an der
stelle wird die türkei wieder eine ganz
zentrale rolle spielen das heißt es wird
eine reihe von gesprächen geben müssen
bevor jetzt deutschland eine einseitige
entscheidung trifft jetzt steht an
erster stelle in der prioritätenliste
das zurückbringen der deutschen
staatsbürger das aufnehmen unterstützen
derer die als ortskräfte mit
insbesondere der bundes wären auch mit
den deutschen zivilkräften sehr eng und
gut zusammen gearbeitet haben es wird
sicherlich auch am ende ein hilfsangebot
geben in dem deutschland sich einbringen
wird da bin ich ganz sicher aber dies
muss diesmal international eingebildet
zweites ich muss rasch gehandelt werden
und deswegen ich will da nicht nerven
wenn ich das nochmal ansprüche weil wir
sie brauchen schon jetzt nato und eu
gemeinsam relativ schnell um sich darauf
verfahren festzulegen nato auch deswegen
weil meiner meinung nach bei der
flüchtlingsfrage vor allem die
amerikaner jetzt gefordert sind denn der
einsatz passierte unter dem oberkommando
der amerikaner und das bleibt auch die
enge verbündete da aber die amerikaner
müssen uns auch darauf eine antwort
geben ausfliegen allein der eigenen
leute das wird nicht reichen diesmal ist
angekommen eine weitere bittere seite
dieser lage in afghanistan ist dass wir
aktuell nicht mehr abschieben in das
land das auch jene wie beispielsweise
die beiden brüder die ihre tochter
ihre ihre schwester einem sogenannten
ehrenmord ausgesetzt haben mit dem
koffer durch deutschland gereist sind
die leiche von mariam dann schließlich
vergraben haben im süden deutschland
sind bayern dass diejenigen eigentlich
durch die lage in afghanistan aktuell
durch diesen abschiebestopp ja eine
dauerkarte deutschland gelöst haben
also das ist jetzt eine unbefriedigende
situation ob sie sicher recht der
abschiebestopp der bund jetzt zunächst
einmal gemacht hat ist sicher
verständlich das wird aber
möglicherweise auch keine dauer
situation sein man muss die lage weiter
beobachten solche morde solche taten
sind
schrecklich und sind nicht akzeptabel
ganz im gegenteil und wir müssen alles
dagegen tun um einerseits noch mal zu
überlegen bei uns
strafmaß und auch
die umsetzung der justiz deutlicher
konsequent an schneller zu machen wobei
der deutschland viel vorangekommen ist
im vergleich zu den vergangenen jahren
darüber hinausgehend ist es wichtig dann
auch möglicherweise mit einer neuen
regierung egal wie sie dann aussieht in
afghanistan da auch zu verhandeln denn
es ist ein unterschied ob sie über
politische gefangene reden oder mörder
da ist das anders grundsätzlich
auszuschließen dass ein mörder bei uns
abgeschoben wird nach afghanistan auch
unter den taliban das kann man nicht von
vornherein zu sagen jetzt machen wir
hatten schnitt herr ministerpräsident
und sprechen über das thema das wenn man
den zuschriften folgt die wir vor der
sendung bekommen haben unsere zuschauer
weiterhin normaler meisten bewegt das
thema corona und viele verstehen nicht
warum ein zentrales versprechen gerade
gebrochen wird nämlich dass das wenn
jeder in deutschland die möglichkeit
hatte geimpft zu werden sei eine impfung
zu bekommen dass dann die
einschränkungen die korona
beschränkungen fallen warum wird dieses
versprechen gerade gebrochen
ja zunächst einmal ist dieses angebot an
alle ja noch gar nichts erfolgt das
würde erst ende september der fall sein
dass man das so sagen könnte kann man
sich jemanden noch ganz kurz dazwischen
gehen ab kennen sie jemanden der sich
impfen lassen möchte und das aktuell
nicht kann
es gibt eine reihe von leuten die jeden
tag sich noch impfen lassen also wir
stellen gerade im moment fest dass die
im nachfrage wieder deutlich wächst also
der beschluss der vergangenen woche war
ein richtiger darauf hinzuweisen dass
jeder sich selber entscheidet ob er sich
impfen lässt oder nicht aber dass damit
auch konsequenzen verbunden sind wie zum
beispiel dass es keine tors kostenlosen
test mehr gibt es der eine teil deswegen
steigen die impfzahlen jetzt wieder das
andere was wir schon merken die
niederschwelligen angebote funktionieren
dass ich muss wirklich noch deutlich
ausbauen bei uns in nürnberg gestern hat
ein gastronom drei im weckla wie man in
einem werkzeug also die nürnberger
bratwürste sind über das kleine
angeboten und hat an einem morgen 4 500
impfungen vorgenommen ich habe das auch
in filderstadt hingehört wir müssen
jetzt versuchen diese prozesse noch
starke zu machen ich glaube dass wir
noch eine menge an impfmöglichkeiten
haben denn dir dir derer die total
radikal dagegen sind sind weniger als
man glaubt und tiere die sich doch
überlegen sich impfen zu lassen ist
größer und haben sollten wir sind alle
bemühungen annehmen dass zu stark ich
glaube dass sich jemand noch viele
überzeugen lassen das ist ja die
hoffnung von uns allen dass immer noch
mehr sich impfen lassen die frage war ja
ob die bisher nicht das angebot hatten
weil das steht ja auch in ihrem papier
dass sie in der letzten em pk
verabschiedet haben das steht ja ganz
vorne im papier drin dass das
impfangebot jetzt an alle geschehen als
dass die regierung dieses versprechen
eingelöst hat jetzt sagen sie ist noch
gar nicht so gewesen jetzt erstmal da
ja ich glaube dass wir da hin zum
übergangsphase sind das spürt man ja
auch durch die ferien sie dürfen nicht
vergessen dass gerade in den ferien
viele ärzte auch selbst im urlaub war
dass das mit den anmelde und für manche
leute waren im urlaub oder sind noch im
urlaub unterwegs und deswegen glaube ich
können wir als realistisch sagen dann
wenn alle ferien vorbei sind dann können
wir eine vernünftige bilanz ziehen dann
ist auch der schulstart der überall mit
abstand das wichtigste ist dass der
gelingt dass wir auf dauer wieder ganz
klar an präsenzunterricht haben der am
anfang mit masken zur sicherheit mit
vielen tests stattfindet und auch mit
luft reinigungsgeräten wo wir wirklich
druck machen auch gerade bei uns in
bayern zum schulstart dass möglichst
viel da angeschafft wird und auch
umgesetzt wird schon vom angebotenen
geld das ist jetzt die absolute
priorität und dann müssen wir sehen wie
sich die inzidenz zahl weiter entwickelt
sie steigt jetzt gott sei dank steigt
auf der anderen seite nicht die
hospitalisierung war jedenfalls nicht
wesentlich deswegen kommen jetzt die
nächsten wochen entscheiden darauf an
dass wir diesmal die richtige
glücksformel entwickeln das war übrigens
das was aus meiner sicht an letzten
woche eigentlich noch gefehlt hat
nämlich ein fairer und ganz konkrete
oder das hat sehr gefehlt da haben wir
uns auch sehr gewundert warum der
eigentlich gefehlt hat weil sie waren
sich ja eigentlich alle einer das
feedback weg davon muss so fokussiert zu
sein abhängig zu sein von der inzidenz
wert also wann kommt ihre glücksformel
also die inzidenz brauchen sie übrigens
immer weil sie müssen einfach wissen wie
viele infektionen sind zum bei wem cindy
infektionen aber die konsequenz die
muster und breiter aufgestellten dazu
gehört im hospitalisierung und auf lange
sicht auch beachtet generell die
impfquote ab der sie dann entscheiden
können ab welchem punkt sozusagen ab
welcher zahl auf welcher quote impfquote
sie von einem relativ geringen
verbreitungs risiko ausgehen können wir
hatten eigentlich gedacht es gibt den
vorschlag von seiten des bundes sw
deswegen auch übrigens gut weil wir eine
einheitliche regelung in deutschland
haben jetzt hat der bund diese zahl rk
ii und bundesgesundheitsministerium aus
welchen gründen auch immer nicht liefern
können jetzt beginnt unter den ländern
so eine debatte jeder entwickelt seine
eigene fahne wir werden uns auch wir
setzen uns ist auch mit unseren experten
noch mal zusammen und da an weg zu
finden ich hätte es besser gefunden wir
hätten eine bundeseinheitliche idee und
philosophie entwickelt ab welchen grenz
und schwellen werden wir wirklich eine
überlastung des gesundheitssystems sehen
müssen denn inzidenz allein taugt
deswegen sofern nicht mehr weil die
inzidenz die wir hatten bei einer
notbremse von 100 heute nicht
realistischer weise die gleiche wirkung
hat aufgrund der hohen zahl der gegen
kanada in allen mustern da in der tat
wenig operieren ja genau das ist ja im
grunde konsens seit wochen mittlerweile
machen sie doch einfach sie haben auch
noch den vorsitz in der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz
einfach am tisch legen die anderen
werden dann schon hinterherlaufen
mehr ganz so einfach ist es nicht sie
wissen ja dass ich generell zunächst mal
gern dazu neige auch mal einen vorschlag
zu machen daran hat ist mit dem
hinterherlaufen es in deutschland immer
sehr sehr zäh am ende ist es so die
haben sie haben schon recht die meisten
kommt dann hinterher aber sind immer
großer großer abstand wenn wir mal
dazwischen haben sich überdies ein glück
sie haben ja im grunde schon geradeaus
formuliert das heißt ich glaube jetzt
gar nicht dass da noch so viel gebastelt
gerechnet werden aber ich weiß ja nicht
das problem
er weiß wie es ist wie bei vielen
anderen dingen sozusagen die bei jeder
anderen chemischen formel die stoffe
sozusagen die die einzelnen baustelle
die sind klar aber wie sie im verhältnis
zueinander stehen also ab welcher
incidents geht man davon aus dass eine
gefährdung für die hospitalisierung
droht zweite frage wann welche form von
hospitalisierung wie wird dalum co wird
auch eingerechnet und sie trauen sich
dann nicht also das muss ich mir einmal
festlegen dann also das wird ja
wahrscheinlich nicht 100% toll sein und
auch nicht 100 prozent schlecht aber man
muss ja irgendwann mal festlegen kommt
diese glücksformel denn dann noch vor
der bundestagswahl trauen sie sich das
sicher sie muss sicher kommen ich hatte
ja letzte woche war eine hoffnung war ja
bei der mpk ich bin ja ein sehr wirklich
orientierter mensch der versucht mir den
kollegen und kriegen es zusammen zu
entwickeln ich hatte gehofft wir haben
letzte woche das war ja auch mein
bestreben dass wir davon eben
weitreichende beschlüsse haben die auch
länger gelten geben muss klar sein wir
werden noch vor vor der bundestagswahl
deutlich höhere instanzen haben wir sind
daran auch eine gemeinsame strategie
also diese hoffnung quasi bekommen ohne
die bundes über die bundestagswahl ohne
dass man sich entscheiden muss dieses
meinen sich nicht wichtig
unterschiedliche länder schlagen jetzt
unterschiedliche möglichkeiten vor alles
bin ich wenn ich das sagen darf noch
nicht ganz ausgegoren ist auch keine
frage von mut in der frage von klugheit
und musste am ende auch stimmen und es
muss ja auch tragen es muss ja auch mit
den medizinern besprochen werden zum
beispiel mit intensivmedizinern daran
arbeiten wir viele kolleginnen kollegen
auch und ich bin sicher dass wir am ende
noch eine gemeinsame formel entwickeln
müssen nur noch können ihr ziel sie
kräftig die daumenschrauben an für
ungeimpfte die die tests leben in
zukunft wieder werden zahlen müssen das
sorgt bei denen doch für einige
aufregung ich will ihn noch einen brief
zeigen von der berliner
gesundheitssenatorin karachi den sie
vermutlich kennen die hat mit ihrer
bildungssenatorin an die schüler und
schülerinnen geschrieben und hat sie
direkt in diesem schreiben direkt
wirklich an die kinder aufgefordert sich
impfen zu lassen finden sie so was in
ordnung
vertretbar es müssen müssen den kollegen
in berlin entscheiden was sie tun
normalerweise glaube ich ist bei
minderjährigen sinnvoll dass man auch
mit den eltern redet mit den eltern
zusammen die entscheidung trifft glaube
das ist der richtige adressat wobei mein
gefühl ist wenn ich ihnen sagen darf
dass sich gerade die jungen leute
manchmal sogar leichter schneller impfen
lassen wollen denn gerade für die jungen
leute auch für die unter 18 jährigen
dieses einfach eine frage von freiheit
und sichere schule und wenn sie die
abwägung treffen zwischen den
möglichkeiten des impfens und
vermeintlicher risiken die alle zig fach
diskutiert worden dann sind die chancen
einfach enorm hoch wissen sie ich finde
auch einige deutschland wir bieten ein
super soziales und freiheitliches
angebot die info und jetzt der impfstoff
der für alle zur verfügung steht dies
auch umsonst verabreichen zu können ist
ein riesiges soziales angebot für alle
egal ob man kosten damit hätte oder
nicht weil es kostenlos ist also frei
und es ist zum anderen auch ein
angebauter freiheit denn am ende ist es
tatsächlich so die sicherste form von
freiheit auf dauer und sicherste form
von stabilität ist das impfen wissen sie
meine sorge ist ja einfach dass wir gar
nicht mal so wir in deutschland sondern
international immer wieder vor der
problematik stehen weil international zu
wenig geimpft wird an einigen stellen
denken sie an den afrikanischen
kontinent oder in asien dann am ende
neue mutationen entstehen und damit auch
die wirksamkeit und die resistenz grad
der impfstoffe herausgefordert wird und
dann haben wir wieder neue
gefährdungspotenziale grommisch zuviel
impfen und so schnell impfen wie möglich
der beste schutz das ist die einzige und
wie ich meine überzeugendste waffe gegen
korona dauert die frage ist mit wie viel
überzeugungskraft man das macht und mit
wie viel druck mit wie viel zwang mit
wieviel pflicht man das macht vor allen
dingen in bezug auf die kinder wie haben
sie das zuhause geregelt mit ihren
kindern mit ihren söhnen
laufen dann noch diskussionen sind die
geimpft wollen die
die sind geimpft und die wollen ich habe
gar nichts sagen müssen sie wollten ist
sehr bewusst
möglicherweise hat der einfluss des papa
ist doch ein bisschen bisschen geholfen
zumindest an der stelle
jetzt weiß ich dass jetzt sagen soll
aber man darf den einfluss von vätern
auf
kinder die in der pubertät sind nicht
überschätzen ist
unabhängig davon übrig davon 1 das ist
eine frage von freiheit sich natürlich
ist es so dass das jeder selber
entscheiden muss daher kann ich bin mir
sind auch von ihm pflichten schauen sie
in anderen ländern unserer partnerländer
frankreich hat teilweise starke
impfpflicht geführt das machen wir bei
uns nicht und ich finde das auch bei uns
sagen wir mal der hinweis auf auf impfen
doch relativ vernünftig jetzt schauen
sie wir sind ein freiheitliches land ist
okay es haben sich immer bei corona
immer noch um eine solche deswegen läuft
es auch über das infektionsschutzgesetz
nicht über andere fragen so und die
frage ist jetzt die entscheidende
botschaft ist du entscheidest ich
entscheide jeder entscheidet selbst sie
entscheiden wollen sich impfen lassen
oder nicht zu und wenn sie sich dann
entschieden haben nicht sich impfen zu
lassen besteht anders als bei allen
anderen dingen geben das problem dass
sie für sich aber möglicherweise auch
für andere herausforderung darstellen
dann übernehmen sie verantwortung für
sich weil sie sie ablehnen zu impfen
aber diese verantwortung müssen sie auch
dann selbst wagen das ist immer dann am
ende so dass sie deswegen auch die tests
mit bezahlen müssen und ich glaube schon
dass das eine zusätzliche wirkung hat
und eine frage der gerechtigkeit und
freiheit ist für unser land darüber dass
die zahl der tests deutlich abnehmen
wird dann vor allen dingen bei den
ungeimpften die werden sich vermutlich
die stelle wird ja wachsen die werden
noch weniger attraktivität haben sich
testen zu lassen
aber es besteht dann auch weniger gefahr
denn 3g wird ja flächendeckend weiter
entwickelt also 3g wird der flächen
deckend weiterentwickelt und dann ist
ganz klar wenn sie sagen würden ich
lasse mich nicht testen ich lasse mich
nicht impfen dann kann es auch passieren
dass sie eben weil sie die tests
ablehnen ist auch dann schwer wird
beispielsweise
dann ins stadion zu kommen oder oder zu
einer bild party zu kommen diesem
problem meiner ansicht nach dass sie all
diese beschlüsse gefasst haben und auf
impfquoten geschaut haben die
möglicherweise gar nicht stimmen wie wir
mittlerweile gelernt haben oder lernen
mussten dass die impfquoten des rk ii
gar nicht die realität abbilden für sie
ist das so ein riesenproblem in der
politik
also das muss man noch mal genau klären
diesen sachverhalt den sie jetzt
ansprechen am ende haben sie auch da
nicht wir brauchen eine einheitliche
vernünftige datenbasis nur es egal wie
hoch die jeweilige quote bislang war sie
muss besser werden sie muss besser
werden und deswegen sind die gesamten
niederschwelligen angebote gut ich habe
gestern gesehen dass in allen
fußballstadien das erfolgt ist auch
schon mit erfolg nicht mehr erfolgt
sondern eben auch mit erfolg und das
gilt ja nur die datenlage nur ganz ganz
dabei die datenlage ist erhält ein
desaster ich habe die hoffnung
die frage ist die da zu klären ist ob
all die gesamten impfungen die bei den
ärzten vorgenommen sind ob sie da
abgebildet sind aber ich stimme hinzu
das muss geklärt werden und da muss der
bundesgesundheitsminister jetzt mit
seinen kolleginnen und kollegen und dem
ärger rasche klärung herbeiführen er tut
es aber sicher auch das weiß ich ein
bericht sorgt aktuell für aufregung
nämlich aus dem us-kongress der ganz
offiziell sagt er es ist davon
auszugehen dass das virus hier sehen wir
das deckblatt dieses berichts des us
kongresses tatsächlich aus einem labor
in wo hahn stammt
wie stehen sie dazu folgen sie dieser
theorie und vor allen dingen was
bedeutet das jetzt für sie für die
deutsche politik wenn nach und nach das
eben nicht mehr in den bereich der
gerüchte der
verschwörungstheorie lebt lee sondern
wenn der us-kongress tatsächlich ein
stempel drauf macht und sagt ja davon
gehen wir aus stammt aus dem
chinesischen labor aus wo hahn
soweit ich weiß ist dass jetzt noch
einen bericht der von einer der parteien
angefordert wurde und dann abgegeben
würde das ist jetzt ganz entscheidend
habe völlig recht diese billig wird dort
diskutiert dann muss natürlich auch mal
die us regierung als ganzes dazu ein
statement abgeben es würde dann sehr
interessieren und auch deutschland muss
diese nicht genau studieren und dann
seine analysen daraus ziehen und möglich
über mögliche konsequenzen diskutieren
ich würde mich da jetzt noch
zurückhalten wenn das so wäre wäre das
schon eine sehr spannende und
herausfordernde situation insbesondere
deswegen weil es dazu keine äußerungen
gegeben hat bislang aber das muss jetzt
mal abschließend geklärt werden auf
jeden fall wird diese bericht für
erhebliche diskussionen zwar für
diskussion und vor allen dingen für
schadenersatzforderungen also das liegt
er jetzt auf der hand wenn sich eben es
wurde ganz lange als
verschwörungstheorie abgetan von
deutscher politik von deutschen
wissenschaftler auch von herrn drosten
unter anderem und jetzt rückt das aber
immer mehr in den in den bereichen
stempel drauf alle hinweise deuten
darauf hin dass heißt das verändert ja
völlig die politische debatte um
schadenersatzforderungen
ich würde mal sagen wir sehen diesen
bericht den ich selber nicht gelesen
habe bislang ich habe über die
berichterstattung jetzt darüber fahren
und deswegen wird es natürlich sehr
akribisch genau analysiert werden sowohl
noch einmal der us-regierung ist schon
wichtig was der präsident der
vereinigten staaten und seine regierung
dazu sagt ist dass die dem offizielle
meinung der usa dann muss das über die
whu auch diskutiert werden auch die
stellungnahme ist wichtig und der
bundesregierung und dann wenn diese
ergebnisse gesichert wären dann hat es
sicherlich eine weitere diskussion
verfolgt also
ich weiß dass man da aus dem ersten
impuls heraus gerne mehr fordern möchte
aber erstmal eins nach dem anderen
diskutieren stimmt ist wirklich in
welcher form in welchem umfang und und
dann zimmer weiter aber wenn diese frage
noch mal abschließt so lange im bereich
der verschwörungstheorie war dann haben
wir uns doch offenbar bisher nicht auch
abschließend damit oder nicht
ausreichend damit beschäftigt wir hatten
ja auch selber seitens der
bundesregierung mehr so einen bericht
anfertigen können oder im parlament
ja gut der zugang erfolgt über andere
möglichkeiten also da würde sie einfach
sehr spannend sein wie diese bericht
bewertet wird ob man den selbst als
glaubwürdig eingestuft wird das
überhaupt keine zweifel daran schön im
gegenteil aber das muss jetzt alles mal
eingestuft werden würde es einfach mal
vorschlagen das ist etwas für die für
für dieses gespräch in zwei oder drei
wochen ok trotzdem wollten sie diese
frage überhaupt geklärt haben bisher
wollte die deutsche politik diese frage
geklärt haben war sie daran interessiert
oder sicher ist ja ganz entscheidend zur
ganz entscheidend woher kommt cologne
ruhe kommt corona und durch was ist es
verursacht worden ist ja ganz
entscheidend in sechs wochen das wird
sie nicht überraschen ist bundestagswahl
herr söder wie groß schätzen sie im
moment die chancen ein dass armin
laschet der nächste bundeskanzler sein
wird
ja es ist sehr hoch und da ist alles
drin aber es ist kein selbstläufer ich
freue mich mittlerweile dass alle
sozusagen erkannt haben in der union
dass wir mehr kämpfen müssen auch armin
laschet ist jetzt hoch aktiv gerade auch
die letzten tage sehr stark geworden man
hat den eindruck in der union sind jetzt
alle bereit endlich den kampf anzug
anzuziehen heißt ja auch wahlkampf und
deswegen bin ich eigentlich optimistisch
aber klar sein muss
es wird eine schwierige situation ich
habe schon ewigkeiten gesagt es wird ein
wimpernschlagfinale ich habe in fast
allen dieser einschätzung bislang recht
behalten so wird es auch sein und es
besteht ist die ganz große gefahr das
ist eine mehrheit jenseits der union
geben kann ist wohl jedem klar sein die
führung durch eine bundeswehr durch die
union was die mehrzahl will die ist
gefährdet es ist ein linksbündnis
aktuell sogar der wieder denkbar oder
auch eine ampel deswegen ist jetzt ganz
wichtig dass die union in anspruch klar
macht aufführung auch die unterschiede
was bedeuten linksbündnisse was bedeuten
auch ampel für eine für deutschland dann
innerhalb zu unregierbarkeit auf dauer
und deswegen muss man das noch mal sehr
sehr klar und deutlich formulieren das
heißt wimpernschlagfinale schon jetzt
erleben wir also dass olaf scholz quasi
auf augenhöhe steht mit armin laschet
naja den umfragen ist zumindest was die
kandidaten bewertung betrifft jetzt ja
kein überragender vorsprung im moment
von uns das lässt sich aber alles noch
mal es geht mittlerweile in diesem in
diesen zeiten auch von abdi moderne
demokratie ist anders als ich das ja
auch viele alte haudegen immer so gerne
vorstellen dass man das alles
langfristig planen kann am ende kommt es
darauf an und wird ganz entscheidend
sein dass wir als union geschlossen
dastehen ich werde alles dafür tun dass
wir an einer gemeinsamen erfolgreichen
wahlkampf cdu/csu haben und armin
laschet als kanzlerkandidaten
unterstützen aber ganz entscheidend ist
auch dass ich noch einmal klar machen
und herausstellen was der unterschied
ist um von einem kanzler armin laschet
zu einem kanzler schulz oder einer
kanzlerin baerbock dafür haben jetzt
noch sechs wochen zeit und das scholz
verteidigte offenbar einfach das erbe
merkel so kommt zur offenbart bei vielen
deutschen im moment an er gehört der
regierung an unterschiede zwischen spd
und union sind sowieso nicht so deutlich
zu erkennen und jetzt scheint er vielen
deutschen offenbar derjenige der nicht
nur sagt ich will den job von frau
merkel sondern vielen deutschen scheint
das auch realistisch
sie haben recht am ende die botschaft
auf den kanzler kommt es an damit ist
die union bei konrad adenauer helmut
kohl und auch bei angela merkel sehr gut
gefahren es muss jetzt die nächsten
wochen entscheidende punkt sein auf den
kanzler in den kanzlerkandidaten kommt
es an deswegen auch volle rückendeckung
keine anderen debatten an der stelle zu
führen keine zweifel sehen ob das jetzt
der richtige oder der falsche kandidat
ist sondern er ist unser kandidat hat
unsere loyalität und solidarität auch im
nächsten wochen verdient wir
unterstützen hin und wollen da als
gemeinsames team erfolgreich sein das
wird jetzt ganz entscheidend sein und
was olaf scholz betrifft ich schätze
olaf scholz menschlich und er ist auch
kein schlechter finanzminister auf
keinen fall aber die wahrheit ist auch
da gab es eine fülle von fragen ob bei
wirecard oder anderswo die alle nicht so
einfach zu lösen waren es kommt darüber
hinaus zur tatsache dass olaf scholz
steuererhöhungen plan für ein großteil
unserer bevölkerung und da wo sie ganz
ehrlich sagen ich traue olaf scholz
nicht zu der richtige kanzler zu sein
insbesondere in einer mehrheit mit
beispielsweise einem linksbündnis mit
einer linkspartei stellen sie sich vor
die linkspartei wäre jetzt nicht bereit
auch nochmal bundeswehrsoldaten allein
zur rettung zur eigenen leute nach
afghanistan zu schicken weil sie alle
ist und jeden einsatz der bundeswehr
ablehnen und noch einmal ich schätze
auch christian lindner als person und
die fdp ist ein einig einen ein guter
ein geborener partner für die union aber
der fdp es dann im zweifelsfall auch das
regieren näher als es um die
gemeinsamkeit mit der union und eine
ampel ist da absolut möglich deswegen
nur wenn die union stark ist und wenn
sie deutlich zulegt hat sie eine chance
selbst bestimmt eine regierung zu bilden
und nicht nur darauf zu hoffen dass die
anderen fehler machen ein name carl
starcke herausstellen und nicht nur auf
die fehler anderer waren einnahme kann
gerade bei ihnen nicht vor annalena
baerbock ist die jetzt in diesem sie
schildern das ist ja ganz offenbar als
zweikampf mittlerweile armin laschet
gegen olaf scholz da nicht mehr auf
augenhöhe nicht mehr wirklich im rennen
ich glaube annalena baerbock ist etwas
abgeschlagen und die grünen sind wieder
auf ein normales maß gekommen was die
umfragen betrifft und die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass am ende auch
eine eine regierung gebildet wird mit
den grünen der führung wie halte ich für
sehr sehr ich glaube sogar er sogar dass
die grünen bereit sind nur um die union
auszubremsen dann am ende sogar der spd
den kanzler überlassen würden und darum
muss man ebenso aufpassen und muss jetzt
auch deutlich kämpfen in den nächsten
wochen es darf jetzt auch keine falsche
falsche vorsicht geben auch gegenüber
der spd
es muss jetzt schon andere klar gemacht
werden was die unterschiede zwischen
armin laschet und olaf scholz sie haben
gerade gesagt sie tun alles um sich in
diesem wahlkampf cdu/csu erfolgreiche
einzubringen erleben sie ab und zu
stimmen in bayern die ihnen gegenüber
treten auf der straße per e mail die
sagen mensch wenn sie tatsächlich alles
tun wollen dann übernehmen sie doch
bitte einfach den
kanzlerkandidaten wahlkampf
ja die gibt es schon und es gibt immer
noch leute die sagen ja das wäre uns
besser gefallen aber es nützt nichts die
die stimmzettel sind gedruckt die
plakate sind geklebt das ist entschieden
und so ist es nun einmal und deswegen
hat es auch keinen sinn der endlos
darüber zu reden oder so zwischen
spekulationen zu machen sondern das muss
jetzt gemeinsam untergehakt und
gemeinsam gekämpft werden ich tun
wirklich alles ich freue mich jetzt dass
auch begriffe über nur anschauen ich
habe die letzten wochen auch immer
wieder die frage der einführung
testpflicht hat so lange gedauert ich
sagte mach schneller ich ja noch mal
ganz kurz zeit zwischen von kostenlosen
tests lassen wir kurz noch sagen die
frage von kostenlosen tests angemahnt
lang gedauert jetzt endlich gemacht
jetzt lasst uns keinen schlaf fragen
wahlkampf machen sondern kämpfen jetzt
wird s gemacht also in allen versuche
ich wirklich ein stück weit motor zu
sein es klappt auch ganz gut und ja es
ist auch so in bayern beispielsweise wir
haben auch nicht die umfragewerte
übrigens vorstellen und klar hätte ich
kandidiert hätten wir zumindest in
bayern bundesweit will ich keine
spekulation machen wirklich nicht aber
in bayern hätten wir natürlich deutlich
höhere prozent erzielt aber das ist
alles so wissen sie
spekulationen die nichts bringt sondern
im kino aber zu spät es ist ja gar nicht
unsere zuschauer hat die frage nämlich
deswegen gestellt weil es ja gar nicht
zu spät ist unsere zuschauer zumindest
sehen das nicht so die sagen nicht jaja
moment mal die plakate sind ja schon
gedruckt und das ist ja halt jetzt
entschieden dann muss man es halt auch
so machen sondern die sagen ist es noch
genügend zeit noch können sie es retten
machen sie es doch bitte herr söder
beispielsweise nina frambach das ist
jetzt eine ausgewählte von tatsächlich
mehren hunderte syrer die uns erreicht
haben und die haben ganz offen gefragt
schicken sie uns ihre frage zu der
sendung mit herrn söder nina frambach
fragt dann hallo herr söder besteht noch
irgendeine chance dass sie zur wahl
antreten die cdu hat auch wohl auch
nichts davon wenn zum beispiel die spd
oder die grünen am ende der die wahl
gewinnen das heißt also nehmen sie doch
ihre verantwortung wahr machen sie ist
halt einfach
das gegenteil ist glaube ich der fall
ich hatte ein angebot gemacht so einer
zeit wo das angebot sinn gemacht hätte
und zwar wirklich an den wahlkampf auch
zu prägen wie ich ihn mir vorgestellt
hatte es gab eine andere entscheidung
die auch voller respektiere ich bin
damit persönlich ganz nochmals sagen wie
oft genug ist das schon gemacht hat ich
bin persönlich der mit fein es hat jetzt
tatsächlich von den zeitabläufen mehr
aus sicht mancher bürger verstehe ich
die frage ich bedanke mich
ehrlicherweise auch dafür sie sehr nett
gemeint es freut mich auch sehr
persönlich aber es bringt nichts
tatsächlich ist es so die stimmzettel
sind überall gedruckt die listen sind
bestellt auch rein juristisch die kann
man gar nicht mehr ändern und deswegen
würde es jetzt auch keinen sinn das
würde übrigens auch ein tobago in der
union an einrichten unter und dazu
müsste er dann auch andere in der union
überhaupt das ganze fordern ich bitte
darum verständnis jetzt müssen uns
unterhaken und ist tue ich tue alles
dafür dass erfolgreich ist das heißt
nicht dass ich deswegen still und leise
bin sondern ich bringe mich schon
engagiert ein damit darf man rechnen
aber jetzt ist armin laschet unser
kandidat und jetzt bin auch sicher dass
der kanzler wird sie haben gerade gesagt
dann bräuchte es ja neben den
stimmzetteln auch stimmen aus der union
die das fordern wir haben angefragt insa
aktuell ob sich diese frage überhaupt
noch stellt ob man darüber noch
nachdenkt auch innerhalb der union und
das ist das ergebnis davon also sollte
die union jetzt auf kanzler söder statt
auf kanzlerkandidat markus söder statt
auf amila schützen das erst mal die
zahlen überhaupt über alle parteien
hinweg da sagen 46,7 prozent der
deutschen finden wir gut und dann haben
wir eben nochmal spezifiziert
unionsanhänger gefragt und da fällt das
ergebnis ganz drastisch aus zeigt das
mal bitte kurz das heißt 62 prozent der
anhänger von cdu csu finden das eine
richtig gute idee
ja schon deutliche zahlen aber was soll
ich jetzt das sagen
sozusagen die die messe ist da
eigentlich gesungen
jetzt haben sie gelesen
eigentlich
ja natürlich nach jetzt kleine
spitzfindigkeit ja sie ist ihnen
zugestanden aber da bewegt sich nichts
mehr es hat auch keinen sinn mehr also
noch mal ist die sache ist jetzt auf den
weg gebracht und jetzt das das hätten
hätten vor monaten hätten da volker
bouffier wolfgang schäuble an anders
sich engagieren müssen jetzt ist die
entscheidung getroffen wir sind damit
vereinigt alle ist dass das klappt in
die richtung an
meiner seite gibt es da keine zweifel
daran sie haben gerade gesagt dann
werden sie im wahlkampf auch immer
wieder so den motor anwerfen das ist
sehr bitter wenn kanzlerkandidaten noch
motor braucht der ihn antreibt
also jeder von uns braucht unterstützung
keiner schafft es allein das wäre
umgekehrt bei mir genauso gewesen ich
hätte starke unterstützung von einem
lasche gebraucht er von mir umgekehrt
genauso es ist auch klar dass wir keine
zwei eigens einen eigenen zweieiigen
zwillinge sind ist auch relativ klar wir
beide sind sehr unterschiedliche
persönlichkeiten haben auch
unterschiedliches temperament haben
natürlich an unterschiedlichen politik
stil aber wie immer es ergänzt ich in
den motorraum motorsegler der kern vom
auto also das wissen sie ja viel besser
da in bayern der wenn der nicht sitzt
dann funktioniert halt gar nichts mehr
wenn der motor nicht drin ist und sie
sagen sie denn der motor von laschet
oder müssen dem den mutter spielen
ohne die csu wird auch schwer sie dürfen
nicht vergessen wenn sie die gesamt
wahlergebnisse herausrechnen würden also
wenn sie das bayerische ergebnis heraus
rechnen würden dann legt die union ja
heute noch mal deutlich anders als bei
23 oder 25 prozent also ist ja ganz klar
genauso wenig wie für die spd bestimmte
bundesländer sehr relevant sind ist für
die union ganz entscheidend wie man im
süden abschneidet und ist es da auch
relativ wichtig und muss man hier auch
gemeinsam kämpfen aber noch einmal die
csu war das ja immer so hat sich franz
josef strauß edmund stoiber nach auch
seehofer verstanden theo waigel viele
andere und da bin ich nur ein ganz brav
in der tradition der csu sagt ja noch
was aus wenn der kanzlerkandidat eben
kein motorrad ich zeige ihnen noch
einmal ein paar fotos aus dieser woche
bzw
bilder vom wahlkampf von armin laschet
wo sie gesagt haben
vor wenigen minuten das ja jetzt auch
langsam er begonnen hat zu kämpfen also
er hat dort in frankfurt im box ring
gestanden was fällt ihnen zu diesen
bildern ein
ja kampfgeist einsatzfreude
da kann noch gar nicht box einsatz
ja das weiß ich jetzt nicht also sieht
man doch so wir haben zusammen wir haben
zusammen noch keinen sport gemacht
aber haben sie es schon mal erlebt im
übertragenen wie das macht das schon mal
ein guter haken oder ja echt haben sie
es im übertragenen sinne schon mal
erlebt wie das ist wenn armin laschet
boxt gegen sie mit ihnen
ja jetzt versuchen sie schon ganz schöne
kriegen psychologie hat zu arbeiten
es liegt ja auf der hand also vorstellen
habe ich nicht erlebt hat eh nix
erlebten ein dass man glaube ich es
waren andere sportarten und andere
waffen als boxhandschuhe und haben sich
schon was an schuhen hätte ich
wahrscheinlich gar nicht so hätte ich
wahrscheinlich dann in denen in denen
dann wahrscheinlich auch möglichkeiten
gehabt mich zu werden ja da wollte ich
küchen psychologisch am ende darauf
hinaus natürlich haben sie schon mal
geboxt in die richtung ich würde sagen
ja nein ich bin ich bin völlig
friedliebend ich bin völlig fit bin ein
ganz friedlicher typ ja alles klar herr
söder vielen dank für die wird das
gespräch morgen findet die
vorstandssitzung bei der union statt das
die abschließende frage ist das eine
absolute krisensitzung eine die ja den
ernst der lage wirklich erfassen wird
morgen
ja muss hier ist schon eine ernste
situation also man kann nicht sagen dass
alles perfekt läuft das hat mit daniel
günther sogar gesagt der von anfang an
und wirklich einer der der wirklich
überzeugten am glühendsten anhänger von
armin laschet immer war
selbst günther ist jetzt plötzlich
skeptisch und etwas ängstlich und er hat
auch recht hat auch eine analyse recht
wir müssen jetzt schon die ärmel
hochkrempelt aber das tun alle das hat
man jetzt ja eine box foto gesehen ich
glaube es ist sehr symbolisch für die
nächsten wochen danke an bayerns
ministerpräsident csu chef markus söder
in die heimat nach nürnberg danke
danke auch alles gute und dass waren die
richtigen fragen bei bild live wir sehen
uns nächsten sonntag wieder dann in
etwas anderem gewand im tv die richtigen
fragen bei bild live
[Musik]